itit ro Jordy I'm here right after a log
and Paul and chaos I fought over
majority draw one George hunted for care
side the other to cut it for a draw
probably the right decision I don't feel
like Logan did quite enough to take the
title away from JJ however for those
first two rounds my jaw was on the float
Logan came up looking like the better
box I was landing the job he was using
his reach he was using his size he was
clowns
he was so robust of it he looked like
he'd been boxing for years like he
wasn't fazed by this one i order and
chaos I didn't want to do he didn't have
an answer for the job us the third round
came JG picked up the piece he started
unconventionally going low one with in
with the hooks that right hook was
landing constantly an imaginary one the
third round he built from that and I
think the fourth round was a close one
and it did seem like Logan's punches ran
out of steam towards the end of the
fight those hard jobs weren't a lot
those hoops weren't as hard and Morgan I
think tire at the end of the fight JJ
was in the ascendancy and I feel like
have not been a 910 rounder JJ would
have ended up winning what this means is
the both odds of agreed to a rematch
which will probably be in America I'll
be gone
and to be honestly I think it's the
right decision for me Logan
on three months notice did amazing
always JJ eventually showed that he's
probably the more technically confident
fighter I've got to say was woken up in
more trailing him it's a really
interesting fight
realize that both can respect each other
so much who's gonna be no talk now about
I'm gonna walk through you we know that
these words are not only even much in
subscribers they're evenly matched in
the grave there was an amazing event
amazing I check the pit of your own
thanks for watching like the video
subscribe our singers liar